hello so first of all I would like to
thank Symons Institute and Simon's
foundation for this great opportunity to
spend the time here it's really exciting
term so today I'm going to speak about
joint work with Johan tournament Justin
thought Justin is here so it's from
University of Waterloo Canada so I'm
going to speak about computing nucleolus
in cooperative matching games so let me
first define the problem we are given a
graph so we're given a set of nodes and
a set of edges and we also given edge
weights so for each edge we have a non
negative weight and as in game theory
usually one has one has value function
so for each subset of nodes we are going
to have some value so we will have a
function mu which assigns value to each
subset of nodes in our case this
function would be as follows it's going
to be a maximum weight of a matching is
matching in the sub graph of G and used
by us so you can imagine that you have
the following problem you have players
they're going to be notes players can
close contracts between each other
and the possibility to have a contract
is described a set of edges each
contract will bring some profit this is
the weight and each collision can gain
together such value so
we so let us assume that we have
additional assumption as an each player
can close at most one contract the niche
collision which will have maximally this
profit which they can get so what would
be like I hope the problem is clear like
we have graph theoretical thing and like
serious interpretation game theory
so yes the players are the nodes
the contracts are the edges each player
can cause at most one contract weights
as the profits and how much profit the
collision of players can get is
described by this value function so what
would you like to get so in cooperative
games here we usually assume that all
players will work together so together
they will get the max weight of a
matching in graph G like so now our task
is to distribute this gain among the
players so this notion is captured by
allocation so we call vector X in army
and allocation little to despise two
properties first of all it is
non-negative and second it is a the
value assigned to all players is equal
to the value
sorry it's usually denoted by nu but my
new is not different from V so I chose
mu so is equal to the total profit of
all players so we would like to
distribute this total profit among
players
I hope so that's are going to be the
objects at which we are looking okay so
of course if we have such an allocation
we for each collision we can compute how
happy is this collision with a given
allocation so for we can basically
compute the following value for each
subset of nodes we compute the
difference which
says how much did we assigned to this
collision - how much this collision
could have gained on themselves this
would be how hype is the collision is so
if this value is positive as a subset of
notes s is happy with allocation because
it could not have done better if all
together if this is negative than
allocation they're not happy this is it
clear
like so for each of the subset of notes
we can compute how happy is this subset
of notes is with our given allocation so
this is how much we allocated to the
given subset of notes - how much they
could have gotten if they like separated
from us all and formed and played on
them together okay so given like here
two sets excluded the whole set we for
this is going to be zero X V minus mu V
is equal to zero by definition and the
empty set is excluded for it is also
zero so now let us sort this so we have
all those entries so for each subset of
notes we can compute this value so we
will sort them in non decreasing Gordon
so for all subsets of notes which are
not empty and not the whole set we
compute the sink and then we sort all of
them in non decreasing order so this
would give us the following crack that
will give us some vector let us say
epsilon 1 epsilon 2 and so all absolute
to be minus
so basically I hope the construction is
clear like so we for if we have
allocation we compute all possible like
how all collisions are satisfied there
will be sort I mean on decreasing order
so basically here stands and the
unhappiest collision among all all of
them then here stands a second
unhappiest collision among all of them
so here stands the solar happiest
collision among all of them and so on so
this vector we will denote as excess
vector like that so we have for each
allocation we can compute such a vector
so now I will define what is simply our
system so nucleolus is basically if we
consider their occasion which gives us
lexicographically maximal vector Epsilon
so we would like to obtain
lexicographically maximal vector here so
you would like to make our unhappiest
collision as happy as possible subject
to that you would like to make our
second and happiest collision as happy
as possible subjects is that you would
like to make our search and happiest
collisions as happy as possible so what
is nucleolus
it's basically Ark lexicographical
maximum of Sita of eggs
this is called nucleus
okay so what is knowing about this
problem
so nucleus wood was defined by Schmidt
law in I think it's early 70s smiled
light defines us in early seventies then
there were some advances on how to
compute the nucleolus for cooperative
matching games
so like polynomial time algorithms to
find nucleolus and there's some other
condition on this allocation function
than these two because I could just set
X arbitrarily large except for for B but
we don't care for B because that's not a
clue I mean this is vector in our V you
do not choose this is like vector narvi
you do not give values to each subset of
nodes you give this is a short
annotation for summation some so there
have been several advances of this topic
so first of all in 94 so via mossy they
gave an algorithm when G is bipartite
and with identical ones
then policeman Kevin and policeman they
give an algorithm when G is general and
Thwaites identical ones zenpo lose my
first general I said G general and
weights not weighted
so I missed some results I was for puja
but spiritually this is the most general
case which one can see that we have jail
graph but the weights of the edges are
defined by some not potentials this is
spiritual is this is different here
so for those graphs they provided a
polynomial time running all the reason
to compute we will thanks it's a great
question no so we showed that I mean
like for cooperative matching games no
we showed that but some versions of the
same are hard so we showed that we can
do
g-general ok so first of all I should
have said in the beginning of the talk I
have to ask for Paula G we do not use
extended formulations but we use
polytope we have some compact
description of some polytopes
but they are not in this we don't use
additional variables we really need
basically polyhedral structure and so
the proof consists of two parts in the
first part one provide like compact
description of some poly tope or one can
interpret the starting case structure of
this poly tope and the second part is
really implementing classical master
scheme which is known in game theory so
I'm going to be focusing only on the
first part I'm going to show the ideas
the second part one knows how to do that
I mean you one could figure out one what
one does one need and we'll write it
down and then just work out so let me
speak about the first part about the
poly tope which we will consider and the
pole
top-4 which will provide a compact
linear description so we would like to
find allocation which provides us
lexicographical maximum here
flexographic our maximum here so I hope
everyone knows what is it's a graphical
maximum is so to give flix a graphical
maximum of course we have to put this
value as large as possible
this should be put as large as possible
because we have to find a location so
that the unhappiest collision is as
possible as happy as possible so let us
find let us write down the LP which
gives us the first value so if one
thinks for some time it's going to be
such LP so we would like to for each
collision have this value Big O equals
an epsilon as in V I included back two
sets one can assume that they're back in
and the total assigned value is the
value of the whole things and we have
Norman a division so this is the LP
basically to find this first entry we
would like for each collision the
difference to be at least epsilon and
people like to maximize this epsilon the
total sign and those two things are
coming from the definition of a location
the total sign to value is the value of
the train collision and everything is a
negative so this is our LP be
okay from here it's not really hard to
move further because we can't move even
further we can simplify these things we
can because our problem has very
matching related structure we can
rewrite this problem
I don't assume you to see that
immediately but one can rewrite this
problem in terms of matchings bingo it
was an absent for all matching M X of B
is equal to MU P and access paper goes
one zero one can turn back to the
definition here and rewrite it so this
is going to be P one for some set s
there would be someone who's not in a
maximal matching you will just remove
them yeah basically it's exactly the
idea because like the words think will
be on zip everything matched yeah so
like if one yeah so one can say that P
and P 1 P 1 they have same value and
also and same optimal solutions optimal
solutions
it's not going to be hard to see so this
is going to be a we will denote this
pile bus sorry physically it may be hard
to see but yeah okay black boy sings its
record instead so and this I will denote
by P one absolute one XFM so basically I
immediately put the weight of the
matching I said that the X of M so this
is going to be the sum of the edges
gisaengs it's a great question so it's
going to be X of M is going to denote
some of the variables in in index by
notes match the better matching M
thanks FM here is going to be a sum okay
so now basically this polytop p 1
epsilon 1 the set of optimal solutions
is exactly the polytope which we want to
study because we know that our nucleolus
is going to maximize epsilon 1 so it's
going to lie in P 1 epsilon 1 so the
starting point now for us will be to
study this poly tope P 1 epsilon 1 which
describes the optimal solutions of both
P and P 1
and actually we would like to start with
a dual of the LPP one but it has quite
strange form so I will write
combinatorially what objects will we
consider we will consider the site of
matchings is going to be the side of
matchings so that X M minus W M is equal
epsilon 1 for all X P 1 absolutely so
basically we define this as a set of
optimal solutions so now we would like
to find out which constraints are really
important for us constraints are here in
degrees by matchings and we would like
to find out what my chinks really
stopped us from getting larger values
and like like intuitive lizards are
going to be exactly those matching
switch which getting the tight vellieux
for each optimal solution so for each
optimal solution they are really tight
I have five five minutes so here okay so
here the trick is going to be to
consider the point from relative
interior of relative interior of P 1
epsilon 1 which we can compute
efficiently and then reformulate this
set of matchings
which are tight for all optimal
solutions as follows mean X star minus W
transpose Y subject to and use Edmunds
formulation of the matching portal Y is
non-negative and Y of Y of s is smaller
or equal to s minus 1/2 yes subset of
notes so the cardinality is odd and yeah
so basically we would like to study the
matching switch stop us in LPP 1 from
getting better values and how we can do
that we can just take the point from the
relative interior of the optimal face
like P 1 epsilon 1 then those matching M
stars are exactly the matchings where X
star M minus W M is equal to epsilon 1
if we take the point from Jarrod
then using this fact we can say that
matchings m star correspond to vertices
of the optimal phase of this LP and here
we use really and suppose it was crucial
to use Edmonds characterization of the
matching Polito which I hope makes sense
immediately like it says that every note
is meshed it most once like all H
variables are non-negative and that in
each odd subset of notes we cannot match
all
not together so from now on crucial
property for us is this the description
namely how the optimal phase of this LP
is defined so you know that optimal
phase for the LP will be defined by
setting some of those constraints at
equality so we will set for some
vertices let us say V those constraints
for quality for some edges those
constraints to equality and for some odd
odd sets those constraints to quality so
we will speak things to set at equality
for optimal face so first of all I would
like to say that we can assume that this
is equal to the empty side because
otherwise problem will immediately
become too easy those constraints not
really important for us and here we will
assume by standard argument that this
forms a lamina family okay so I started
5 minutes later know if epsilon 1 is at
least 0 then it's easy case episode 1 is
going to be negative like if absent 1 is
bigger than 0 in game theoretic sense
it's say it's at like core is non empty
in graph theoretical sense it says that
max weight of a matching equals to
Marc's weight of a fractional matching
so this situation is very nice is the
case which is really difficult is when
absent one is negative thanks it's very
good question
so the now we I would like to say some
words about those cells which are from
Lyman a family so Lyman a family
basically let me simplify it first like
in Lyman a family we basically can
choose inclusion wise maximal subsets
which do not intersect I will I will
just I mean not giving definition we
will just pick some sets which are
inclusion wise maximum maximal in the
lamina family so now now we are able to
prove so the key for us really the key
for us is to prove the following fact
for each X from the optimal phase so in
particular for nucleolus we will have
two properties first property is that if
two nodes U and we belong to the same
set as I star I want okay then the
deviation from X star value is the same
so basically all nodes in the inclusion
wise maximal cells in the lamina family
behave in the same way they all starts
to deviate from our relative interior
point by the same amount
it's very nice property and second
property is that for all edges so that H
does not lie in ye so that the H does
not lie itself in any inclusion wise
maximal set those edges corresponds to
happy collisions so they assigned value
minus the value of this edge it's not
negative so those two key properties are
going to be will give us possibility to
find the nucleolus so basically we took
this poly tope which describes optimal
solutions here and we wanted to exploit
its properties we went through the
relative interior point of the Spota
which we can find efficiently with Zen
we formulated like matching problem for
a function generated by this a relative
interior point and from there we already
could characterize the whole positive P
one excellent one I think I'm yeah I
think things that's it I will stop here
[Applause]
what about all these other algorithms
are there also use using LP type method
or toriel all right
actually it's a good question they use P
type method so here I actually yes
so they arrive at this point like they
arrive at this point from there as they
look for like here in the node weighted
case they basically take Edmonds kalida
composition which they can compute and
then they work as they play with that
but unfortunately for general weights it
doesn't make much sense like if one
consider said math about the composition
it would not bring us anywhere so they
arrive at this point and this point they
constructed misguide the composition and
they know how the my chinks look like
for others matchings would not work
which they consider
so for one of the classes of cooperative
games and compute the nucleus the
context games I think a Barona had
recently paper honesty pass like
algorithm for new clothes for steep-ass
games yeah I mean I Pro yeah I mean
there are I would probably not be the
right person to ask for the full list of
result
good
[Applause]